in the latest philanthropy issue of Town
and Country magazine legend shared his
new initiative in the fight for criminal
justice reform we sat down with the ten
time Grammy Award winner before his
upcoming tour it first hour that's where
Town & Country space and he opened up
about why this issue is important to him
on a personal level I think when people
here at criminal justice reform I think
a couple of things happen either they're
very passionate and engaged their eyes
glaze over like oh god we're talking
about again or it involves race and it
scares people what do you say John to
really make people understand why you
feel so passionate and committed to it
we are the most incarcerated country in
the world we have 5% of the world's
population and we have 25% of the
world's prison population that means we
lock up people at a higher rate than any
other country in the world but people
say look John they broke the law
should they be in prison breaking the
law is their choice you're making to the
laws aren't handed down from God these
are laws that we as society have decided
upon we can change those laws if we over
punished we can decide as a society that
we've over punished we sentence children
in America to life without parole no
other country does that we don't have to
do that
I do think things are changing this
country's people pain don't you and I
think it's actually been bipartisan
which is in 2015 R&B superstar John
Legend launched free America an
initiative focused on bringing awareness
and change to issues involving mass
incarceration
every time we lock someone up it's a
choice we're making we're saying we're
going to invest dollars into keeping
people in cages or we could have
invested that money into making their
communities better making them safer
healthier better educated so they were
never in trouble in the first place so
many communities and families have been
destroyed
I personally seen the effects of
incarceration on my own family
what do you mind what do you mean by
that that you personally my mother had
had an issue with drugs when I was
younger and she was in and out of jail
during my teenage years I've never heard
I've talked about a little bit and in
this context of saying when people have
drug problems and we know that the
opiate crisis is challenging a lot of
communities around America and I think a
lot of families know that when people
have drug problems what people don't
really need is a lot of punishment they
need a lot of help and legend is wasting
no time taking action he recently
launched unlocked futures a program that
will invest in business and
entrepreneurial ideas for people who
have been released from prison we're
going to provide some money to seed some
entrepreneurs who have come out of
prison and want to change their lives
they've developed a skill while they've
been in prison and we want to give them
a chance to innovate to work to create
jobs themselves for themselves and for
other people in their community yeah so
you're not just giving them a job you're
giving them a chance at owning their own
business absolutely you made the time
100 list this year in part because of
your work in this in this area Harry
Belafonte wrote your intro what did you
think about that I was really honored
and I've known mr. Belafonte for years
now and I've been inspired by him for
years even before that he's done some
amazing things in his life and he's made
a lot of great music and great
entertainment for people but he also
throughout his career was committed to
justice he was marching with dr. King he
was helping to fund these marches that
were that are now iconic and he's always
been
example of an artist who used his
platform to make change and I look at
that kind of artists as an example for
me other kind of artists I want to be
Legend recently released his fifth
studio album darkness and light he calls
it his best and most personal he says
he's excited to share it with fans on
his upcoming tour he and supermodel wife
Chrissy Teigen are planning to use their
preferred method of travel a good
old-fashioned tour bus we're gonna be on
the bus we're gonna go and Chrissy
Teigen do not seem like bus people no
offense we all right suburban I've been
doing don't seem like bus B I've been
doing my tour bus since I started this
business and I enjoy being on a tour bus
it's like it's a very luxurious tour bus
it's sort of like a rolling home yes
exactly and now it has a crib that new
amenity is for one year old baby Luna
legend says being a dad has given his
politics a greater purpose and he's
enjoying every single step of first-time
parenting what's your favorite nickname
for her I call her Luna a lot just
because I feel like I don't want to over
nickname her because I feel like her
name is her name and we want to call her
that we call a Luna Lulu Makar Looney
Tunes sometimes I like loony toon toons
you have a favorite little song
everybody makes up a little make up song
that they do oh my god my worst and best
song okay it's all the same okay okay
let me hear I just want to buy it's it's
for when I'm changing her diaper
somebody's got a stinky booty her name
is Luna and she made a poopy somebody's
got a stinky booty and daddy's gonna
clean it up that's terrific tell ya guys
I'm with baby Luna he and Chrissy both
and you we talked about Chrissy opening
up about postpartum he was very glad
that she did that because he thinks it
can help other people he's very very
involved in this criminal justice system
it means a lot to him yeah I mean he's
an incredible artist but thinks so
deeply about social change yeah cuz I
said when people commit the crime
shouldn't they be in prison he goes yes
if the laws were equal that's the point
it's a subject that a lot of people get
involved in
I think Americans and others in
Republicans and Democrats it's an
important issue puddings ran all that we
had on earlier exactly right that person